first of all really excited in the
Omegas day we this is the largest crowd
I think we've ever had in here and
really just probably reached we have
really gotten everybody so excited about
this event we've had it several times
and I guess either word was good or the
advertising was better this time well we
keep having more and more people and to
respect your time I've tried to write a
little something here to try to explain
the idea behind stay behind the science
cafe that we started four years ago with
GPSS and pathways to signs and it begins
like this does knowledge or science
tickle your fancy then I think you come
to a good place to start we are here
because you might wonder what would it
be like what would it be like it I was
to step in the shoes of a young
scientist shoes that I may want to fill
one day myself not so many years from
now where would my shoes walk on the
horizon of human knowledge and what
mines there what rich Islands continents
and oceans away scientific discovery the
horizons that are years and years away
from the pages in my textbook today and
who will my quest impact so we brought
some rock star graduate students as
marine license oldham young scientists
to show you what cutting-edge science
lies in the edge of human knowledge
today even here in your hometown New
Haven and we want to tell you about how
their world-class labs and their very
own research and personal effort their
personal story helps lay a siege on the
edge of the known in our very own talent
we want to show you why research matters
how it will impact the
daily lives how is it done but wont to
do so from the perspective of the shoes
that you could fill over coffee snacks
and shared personal stories of how we
got to where we are today and why we
decided to devote our lives to this
pursuit what is our walk of life like
but then most importantly we're not here
to just talk to you we're here to answer
your questions and so I encourage you to
seek out all the people with nametags
and graduate students and we'll break up
into discussion groups after the
presentations though we three to four
discussion groups excuse me three for
each of the three speakers so you can go
and ask them questions Mississippi
face-to-face one-on-one and they'll be a
fourth discussion group will have the
rest of the graduate students from
different fields so we can represent the
broader array of your interest so
without further ado let's begin let me
introduce the grad the lineup of our
students graduate rock star students
today so first we'll zoom out from our
seats here on earth in this room and
journey to the explosive surface of our
burning Sun where Daryl Seligmann a
young PhD scientist in the Astronomy
Department back here on earth and Yale
will take us on a tour of what goes on
there through his stellar research in
stellar customer
then we will work back in space but not
to earth but to the difficult to a sale
land in our minds and Sharif a PhD in
the biology and biomedical sciences
department here back on earth well twist
the fabric of our minds as he dies with
us on a quest of the meeting of
consciousness suddenly we will find
ourselves traveling not through space
but through time on a planet so
unfamiliar yet it will be revealed that
in the secret past of our earth through
the research of Robin kanavan a PhD
student back on earth today the geology
department and geophysics department
here at Yale works you fats because the
most valuable part perhaps of this whole
thing will be after the talks when you
can ask your questions one on one with
the speakers and will have tags labeling
each of the locations back there and so
we can continue to have a light snack
some coffee and we'll break up into the
groups with the three speakers and the
graduate students back there by the
tables and so our request is not in here
but it is only the beginning of your
quest and after the event you can get in
touch with any of the speakers so they
can address any for your questions you
might have maybe even visit a loud one
day so thank you guys would be part of
this thank you for taking time from your
sunday Thank You pathways and GPSS for
funding and let us begin our journey
through space and time and meet darrow
on the surface of the sun but first I'll
tell you about Darryl so Darryl sent me
a vile but I
the liberty to rewrite it Darryl there
was a human earthling as an Eagle Scout
back on earth he loves all outdoor
oxygen activities from backpacking to
scuba diving and most certainly sports
in high school in Philadelphia area he
wrestled play football and rugby at the
University of Pennsylvania he double
major in the physics and math and now he
is a first year PhD in the Astronomy
Department his in his research interests
include and here here it goes solar
Astro physics cosmology specifically
magneto hydro dynamics helioseismology
gravitational lensing and dark energy
she's trying to making that into a
raptor and he will tell us what all
these mean in his stellar astrophysics
talk please help me welcome Darrell so
it goes from very passive to very active
back to pasture and so in 11 years is
from passive to active and you don't
really that's not really don't underst
I want to talk to you guys today about
stellar astrophysics or just more
commonly known as study of the stars
first though I just want to say how
inspiring it is to me that so many of
you guys are here today and took your
free time on sunday I'm going to learn
about science from grad students because
it really reinforces this idea that I
have and this idea I've had is actually
been proven to me over and over and over
again around my life and that's that
people are fascinated by the universe
and people love science and there
actually might be a little more
fundamental than that I think that as
humans we inherently have this drive to
want to figure out what's happening in
the universe and our place and kind of
unravel the mysteries of the cosmos so I
don't think there was ever any one who
it was a clear night and they went out
and looked at the Stars and sold them to
anyway and you know they didn't wonder
what the stars were and how they got
there and what our place in the cosmos
is okay and I'm not talking about just
today I'm talking about throughout time
so early all throughout ancient
civilizations one constant is that all
civilizations look at stars and made
constellations so they were looking at
patterns in the stars and projecting
what they saw in the natural world is
the heavens so one consolation that
everyone knows is the Big Dipper and
this is a great consolation the grief
spoke with a big dipper person major was
a bear but the Egyptians actually
thought that the Big Dipper looked like
a hippopotamus inside okay what was
going on here so they didn't have bears
in Egypt but they actually did having
fun so they were taking what they saw
world I'm projecting that onto the stars
and what's so cool is that the other way
around was also going on so there's this
theory that the three Pyramids of Giza
were actually built aligned three stars
and Ryan stuff so um the Sun was
actually central to the Egyptians
religious belief so there may God's rock
and browse the god of the Sun and he was
the most powerful guy in the Egyptian
mythology and the bigot here is raw on
his boat and every day as the sun goes
across the sky rise supposed to be
carrying the Sun in hope across the sky
and then it's sunset Rogers into the
underworld and that shown here Roz
actually playing the serpent eight men
who is according to Egyptian for more
details and what's called me is that the
reason that the Sun is so central to
their religious to settle their lives
right there old landing hood was based
on the Sun because that cross room
doesn't son um yeah and so there have
been a lot of theories about stars
wrapping these three
your own ever wonder would those
sparkling dots off I wondered I know
what are they get free of my applies got
stuck up in that thang bluish-white
thing oh I always thought they were
balls gas burning billions of miles you
everything space but what's going to be
actually is that as little as two moon
knows about stars we really aren't in
that much a better place right now so we
know very little about the stars and
it's not a crazy that they think the
universe in astronomical terms the Sun
that is one of the closest astronomical
objects to us but we really don't know
that much about we know more than bone
but so yeah so goombahs right okay these
stars are these big balls of gas but
they're not passive they're actually
extremely active in volatile and there
are big solar eruptions that happen all
the time so it's like on earth or
volcanoes going off in a couple weeks
and they can be big solar flares or
coronal mass ejections which are
basically a big explosion and then the
masculine son is ejected into space and
this is a video that was taken in two
thousand April 2015 from the Solar
Dynamics Observatory and made some
aspects
the Phoenix comments so many of em
speaks for itself really awesome but
watch here there's going to be a big
explosion here yeah so it's pretty it's
pretty amazing that we have the
technology now to actually see it like
this but one thing I want to point out
is that this was actually taken in
extreme ultraviolet way this is really
high-energy light that you're watching
and you would not be able to see this
with the naked eye so actually stealing
these great spots on the start there was
actually a few dark if you're looking in
the visible light and so the question is
what are these dark spots on the Sun so
first in the 1600 Galileo discovered
that there were some spots and he
observed things like this and scientists
later discovered that these sunspots
when you have of an active regions they
have a lot of magnetic activity and
magnetic activity makes the temperature
go down and so it shines less right so
it's not that they don't shine they just
shine a lot less bright than the rest of
the story and now if you zoom it with
some stupid songs but they actually come
into these pairs so it's this is
actually a north-south magnetic pair it
just like better at a bar magnet or a
couple of our diamonds in the north and
south ends attract each other that's the
same thing that's going on here and I
just realize that it's these active
regions that actually are associated
with the big explosions so the coronal
mass ejections and the solar flares
happen in these active regions so they a
bigger that the magnetic activity must
be what was hiding the solar players and
there's this idea that they came up that
this process that they observe right
it's called magnetic reconnection and
here's a paper from 2015 of this was
bordering
flair they're actually these loops but
the particles are frozen into the
magnetic field so you're actually seeing
the magnetic field at the surface of the
star and the idea magnetic reconnection
is your have a group and then it's in a
really high energy state and then these
field lines great and they reconfigure
themselves in a lower energy
configuration but this energy has to go
somewhere so that's the energy that goes
into the coronal mass ejection of the
flag so here well you've got high energy
state of the twist of the magnetic
fields then it breaks here and then it's
a lower energy state and use when it
breaks there that's when the flare hands
and another thing the stresses you're
going telling you about this we really
do not understand this process so we see
a happy but we don't have a good grasp
of the physics behind it so it's very
active part of research right now and
it's really exciting time as the
National Solar Observatory is building a
huge solar telescope in Hawaii and we're
going to be able to observe magnetic
reconnection with much better resolution
and that's when we online in the next
five years so it's really exciting time
for solar physics okay so now with this
in mind I want to show you another
criminal master section this happening
in jun 2015 but i want you guys to watch
for the magnetic reconnection journey
the flare so first we just got to fold
this view of it here's the player or the
mass ejection and now to exhume and i
want you guys to look at the field lines
and look look at the high energy before
the flare then jury hears the higher ed
right so we've got high engine
configuration it breaks and now but wait
for it now we've got a big explosion and
we've got a lower energy configuration
so yeah it's me it's so cool that we
have technology that we can watch this
going on right now so besides from the
fact that it's really
why do we care about this like why are
why is the government funding people
like me to do research on this well the
Sun is actually one of the only
astronomical objects that directly
impacts our life on Earth so every time
there's a flare or mass ejection all of
that mass and energy and magnetic flux
that's coming straight to earth and when
that hits earth it messes with our gps's
it messes with satellites messes with
airplanes and our solutions actually it
wasn't billions of dollars in damages
every year so the government really
wants to find out the mechanisms behind
the solar place so they can prevent
these damages um another reason that we
want to study the Sun is that what I
understand properties of all the stars
in the universe and there are tons of
stars in the universe and Sergeant us
like people they're born then they grow
up then they get old and they die and
son our son is a grown-up sorry but we
want to buy figuring out what's
happening with the grown-ups are we want
to extrapolate I figure out what's
happening with all ages of sellers this
is a exciting point actually another
reason we want to study it is a lot of
drivers now we're looking for planets
that are in other solar systems so these
are planets that orbit other stars they
hold on exoplanets and the one of the
ways in which we find XO plated is so if
you're observing the star look for the
change in the white when excellent
in front of the star and so okay say
this projector is the start and then my
hand is that complaining so you're
watching you see how much light is
coming to the screen and then this
exoplanet goes by and when it's in
between us and the projector there's
less total light now the issue is that
save you're looking over started and big
as a sunspot or it gets a solar flare if
the light is changing due to the Stars
activity how do you distinguish that
from maxsa planet so this is one of the
most active fields of research in
shanties there um a third reason a
fourth reason is another application of
how the Sun and effects life on Earth is
every time there's a solar storm it
introduces these beautiful Horrors and
actually there was a solar storm last
week and you can see your or is not that
far north from here and so yeah that's
the end of my talk thanks for listening
to me she loves to run and enjoys
literally runs throughout New Canaan's
beautiful parts but don't be surprised
if you see him the zooming by as an
undergraduate he was nationally ranked
in the 800-meter anyway 8,000 meter runs
along the way he received a master's
degree in cognitive neuroscience from
the University College London and a
bachelor's degree from ohio wesleyan
university now Sharif was a first-year
near scientist new science PhD student
here at back on earth legale he is most
interested in studying consciousness and
how people think using magnetics and
electrodes but I promise he wants that
the electrodes he will tease our brain
and explore debts that have seldom been
reached please help me welcome show me
how do you connect the neural activity
with the conscience if that that neuron
the fires are pain is the only thing
that's involved in you feeling pain
where is it where is the pain the ion
channels opening and then neuron
activate what is consciousness this has
been debated for literally thousands of
years but for our purposes will say
consciousness is two things first it's
how something feels and second it's your
ability to think about yourself other
people and work now over the course of
these hundreds and thousands of years of
people trying to figure out what is
consciousness where's consciousness to
competing positions have come into
existence and those two competing
positions are materialists and doors
well tell you about them now so start
with the materials or materialism so the
materialists tell us that consciousness
is fundamentally a physical phenomena
and in particular it's something that
happens in the brain your brain is
making consciousness happen through the
cells sin accent the activity the
talking that's going on between your
neurons in your head now the opposing
position dualism tells us something very
different it said that the universe is
fundamentally to think on the one hand
we have physical stuff stuff that's made
of matter stuff is made of atoms
molecules
proteins bricks concrete steel things
that you can see that you can touch that
you can smell but then there's this
other piece of the universe which is not
visible they call it in material
nominated at it's not made of matter and
they tell us that consciousness is
fundamentally within this fear of a
material thing a non-physical plane so
we had two competing positions we have
the materialist consciousness in the
brain and the Duelist say that
consciousness is a non-physical things
an immaterial phenomenon so what I'd
like to do now is I'm going to challenge
our view of these two opposing theories
with the following five fairy married
the color narrow side hey a little story
of Oedipus so here's Mary she's a
brilliant neuroscientist who lives a few
decades from now and she knows
everything there is to know about how
color is processed in the brain so she
knows exactly about how the photons of
light enter your eye reach the back your
I called the retina the retina process
the information brings it all together
and down the optic nerve goes always the
back door wrangler that
here where the brain begins to process
the vision through very soldiers so she
knows every single step in this process
there were nothing more than Mary can
learn about how color visions processing
brain but here's the thing about there
she's never seen colored gems me she's
completely out of line not the Nano
green red color blindness she's never
seen color at all so she sees the world
in black white red but one day with our
fancy technology of the future were able
to restore her color vision so now she
can see color and let's say we present
to marry resistors quarter color vision
and we have this beautiful red rose and
let's say we present that red rose in
there my question to all of you is what
will her reaction be when she sees that
red rose does she look at that red rose
in the light in surprise oh my goodness
I could
imagine red to be so vibrant red could
be so pretty or does she look at that
red rose not surprised her struggle
shoulder to say something like I already
knew what record even though i'd never
seen room because i knew exactly how
ready and all color is processed in the
brain so it's now your time to decide ok
she's surprised or she's not surprised
so show a hand for surprised when she
sees that red rose ok over half hey show
hands for not surprised ok ok I like
repeating positions here right here as I
said this is gonna debate so not
surprisingly the pendulum to respond to
tell us something important about that
debate between the coolest and materials
so for the two-thirds of unit said she
will be surprised as tantamount to
saying that dualism is true and
materialism is false and the reason for
that is if you remember she knows
everything there is no about how color
visions process in the brain but that
knowledge wasn't enough to tell her
about the consciousness and so what that
tells us is that the consciousness part
of it is outside of her knowledge and
therefore outside of the physical world
the stuff that she knew now there's an
additional implications of that we can't
really study consciousness fun of them
in it this is true because it's
non-physical we don't have the
technology nor I suppose we'll never
have the technology to probe something
that's non-physical like now if you set
the exact opposite about a third of you
she's not surprised what we had the
opposite into patient so now materialism
is true dualism is false and again the
reason for this is her knowledge of
color vision and how its processed in
the brain was all she needed to know to
tell her about the
consciousness of color and the the
additional implication that we can study
consciousness because it's a physical
thing it's a brain now personally I am a
passionate to a cheerless materialist
and as materials one of the things I'm
interested in doing is studying how
competent is processing the brain and so
let's get back to the original question
of this presenting which is where is
conscious in the brain and this is
something that I'm very interested in
studying and there's really two theories
on where my immigrant and here's the
first so the first year we said that
consciousness is in one place in the
brain so there's one special place where
all the information your brain sort of
comes together and that place in the
brain turns it into a conscious
experience theory to says something
different it said that lots of different
places your brain are being involved in
consciousness so it's a collaborative
effort various places in the brain are
working together to make you contrary
hey now the reason why answering this
question is so important it's not only
just for curiosity's not only for
solving a debate that's been going on
for literally 3,000 4,000 years but
there are people who have unusual
conscious states here are a few examples
of those clinical populations people
with epilepsy people who are in minimal
or vegetative States and people who have
locked in syndrome and there's many more
than when I was in here and with a
better knowledge of how consciousness
works and where it is we love
to treat these populations much better
than we do today so let's move on now
and talk about some of the research I'm
doing at Yale in the lab of dr. how
blumenfeld has been studying this topic
or quite some time so we're using the
special technique called deg so here i
am with an EEG device on my head and all
who are electrodes are coming out and
this is how it works so your brain is
constantly talking to itself there's all
these cells about 10 billion of them and
they're all talking to one another and
one of the ways they talk is with
electrical signals and sometimes those
electrical signals sort of leak out of
your head and what we're able to do with
eg in these electrodes is we're able to
capture those leaking signals and
actually good news for us is those
signals tell us a lot about what's
happening inside your head so we have
subjects who we put this EEG device on
their head and then we have them
complete a consciousness test so this
toilet that's works so we show them a
computer screen nothing on in this first
and then a few moments later a face pops
up and then we ask them did you see the
face but here's the thing the face
flashes very quickly so about half the
time they say nope didn't see the face
and the other half the time they say
yeah I saw the face so essentially half
the time they're conscious of the face
and the other has other than not and
what we're interested in doing is
understanding how the brain activity
differs between those two states the
conscious state and the unconscious
state so let's look at some results so
when our subjects say no didn't see the
face they're not conscious this is what
we see we see activity just in the back
of the brain in a place called the
occipital lobe of the primary visual
cortex so this is the part of the brain
that deals with color I'm sorry with
vision and also can do things like that
as well but just vision
in general and this makes sense because
we're asking them to do a visual task
they're not sitting there you're looking
and so we expect to see activity in the
back of brain that's always but now when
they are conscious of the face we see
something different so we first see
activity beginning back into visual area
again and then a few moments later hop
slow forward then it jumps all the way
to sort of the top front of the brain
and then finally ends and moving to the
bottom front of the brain here so what
we're seeing when someone says they're
conscious is this dynamic motion
movement of activity across the brain
and so now let's go back to those two
theories that we were initially talking
about so remember theory one sense
consciousness is one place in the brain
and theory who says consciousness is a
collaborator and effort occurring across
various brain networks so again I'm
going to have you show your hands for
theory one based off of our evidence the
re 22 supports 32 okay so that's really
where we're thinking the three switches
is going down and the previous research
has showed this is also seems to be a
case what parts of the brain are being
involved in producing a conscious state
now this is how I would like to end
today which is i need your help okay
this is a challenging subject and people
the smartest people who have lived for
hundreds of years have attempted to
answer some of the questions we talked
about today and it still remains a
profound mystery perhaps the greatest
mystery so I need all of you who are
interested to become neuroscientist
become psychologist and even
philosophers they have a role to play
and so we can come together and work on
solving these issues and perhaps if
we're all on the same
page we're all doing the same type of
research we can be the last generation
to say that consciousness was a mystery
thank you I'll take any questions Robin
lost hiking canoeing camping and it is
often staring and rocks on the ground
instead of the scenery around her her
work allows you to combine a love of
nature with a curious mind she got a
master's degree at the University of
Wyoming also in geology geophysics where
she studies the uplift history of the
high Andes Mountains Robin is a graduate
student here in yo back on earth in the
department of geology and geophysics and
Yale she focuses or brother uses a
technique called clump isotope paleo
thermometry to estimate past
temperatures during greenhouse climates
at a time when there was little to no
ice on earth on Earth's poles outside
lab her dream is to encourage other
young scientists those who have ever
collected seashells or maybe baking soda
volcanoes to get even more excited about
the natural and physical sciences today
she will guide us on a tour through time
of Earth's vast and rich history in
science and its origins please help me
welcome Robin Wright I'm Robin i am a
geochemist and I study kidded climate so
that means i look at the chemical
signature of rocks fossils and try to
better understand the Earth's climate
through its long history so before we
delve into the rock record though and
try to understand the mystery of our
past earth let's take a moment to just
visit our current this is a image of
Hurricane Joaquin that hit in October
second this year and as you can see from
the International Space Station and as
you can see this is familiar there's
cities in the distance we live in these
cities there's the storm forming off the
Atlantic Ocean that we all know here in
New Haven right at our front door the
continents at this time we know this map
we see it in our history books in our
geographic books and there's ice at the
poles like sock insane now the earth of
the past looks very different and looked
very different at different time periods
very different from what it looks like
today what did the earth look like and
its humble beginnings well not that
different but a bunch of other rocks
zooming around solar system time two of
those such rocks the proto-earth and the
proto moon collided violently 4.5
billion years ago producing a mass that
spewed out and gravity did the work
after this violent collision of
following all the densest material to
the Earth's core the least dense became
the Earth's crust and all of that
material that was ejected out from this
collision consolidated in orbit around
the earth and became the moon now we can
get an age of this collision but
unfortunately not from any rock material
on earth due to the conveyor boat
conveyor belt emotions of the
Earth's crust tectonic plates override
each other and then sink below each
other so a lot of Earth's oldest press
the record of that is a race so how do
we actually know the age of this
collision we study lunar rocks one of
the ways we can do that is using a tool
called radiometric dating now when rocks
or minerals crystallise they basically
set their chemical signature except for
radioactive elements radioactive
elements like uranium decay at a known
rate to leg and thus we can look at say
this moon rock from the Apollo missions
which is rich in uranium and look at the
ratio of uranium to let estimate its age
so based on uranium lead dating of the
rocks we know that the earth-moon impact
and thus the formation of the earth was
4.5 billion years that is a big number
to kind of wrap it with and picture so
to help demonstrate that I would like to
ask for too long here from the audience
to come up here and Toby if you would
people want to raise your hands yep come
on up another volunteer yeah come on so
I will ask you to stand over here if you
can take this end from here grab this
purple in you take this and just swap
that way watch where you going keep
going keep gun
so this is a start the student knit for
me actually but the length of the star
represents 4.5 billion years total
length so we have the earth-moon impact
right here at this end this fringe and
all the way down here on this ribbon we
have almost by the purple frames on the
other end the evolution of humans so
that's a lot this is what we call which
y'all just called deep time slot and for
those of us who like myself professors
as a kid this ribbon right here if you
have one of the first dinosaurs it's not
really a lot of time between those two
when you look at the whole piece revered
and if you keep going all the way back
in time somewhere around here you have
the oldest fossils ever the oldest
evidence of life so there's a lot of
time in between and a lot of interesting
period in which earth look very
different so thank you ladies for
helping out we can just wrap this bed so
to go back to Earth's early beginnings
right before regularly hi to the first
sign of life this is what earth would
have looked like the earth was thirty
percent less bright than it is our de
sons re was thirty percent less bright
than it is today suggesting it would
have been a lot colder but the rock
record shows evidence of marine
sediments suggesting that there was
liquid water now scientists think this
is due to much higher concentrations of
greenhouse gases which makes sense
because Earth's internal engine was
turning much more back fence he would
have had a lot of optimism which so I
there's volcanoes back here medicines
now those marine sediments from this
ancient time period show evidence of
reduced forms of iron and sulfur
suggesting that there was little to no
oxygen on the planet so you and I would
have not survived this would not have
been happy place for us to live in and
in fact most of the critters had some
other way of making their living back
then that is until about 3.5 million
years ago when the first photosynthetic
organisms evolve these guys blue-green
algae or cyanobacteria lived in these
maps which you can see here hold
stromatolite and the evidence for them
spewing out oxygen basically the waste
product of photosynthesis comes in what
we call banded iron formations this
qualitative evidence of the oxygenation
of Earth's atmosphere shows dark bands
of anoxic primary reduced iron and
oxygens of red iron showing how this
slow process of oxygenating Earth's
atmosphere was happening so
unfortunately oxygen poisoned everything
back then but it was great for us right
and everything that came forward after
it dinosaurs including now this
qualitative evidence of the rock record
is commonly used by
climatologists another example is a drop
zone here's a Mueller holder that fell
in really fine laminated beds of marine
sentence as well as this Corley sort of
glacial till here these are both
geological rocks that are produced by
glaciers and were found in low latitudes
about 600 million years ago suggesting
that glaciers from the poles move all
the way to the tropics during this time
period this has become a period
well-known by geologists an earth
scientist as snowball earth um and
that's pictured here in a cartoon you
can see this process is started by what
we call a positive feedback loop so you
have ice form at the high poles it's
bright it's light color it reflects
solar radiation which cools the earth
which feels more ice and so on and so
forth until you have a sort of runaway
ice house so how do we get out of this
if we're a giant snowball why are you
here why is life here well the earth is
still turning the insides molten rock is
still moving around and eventually
volcanoes kick in spew out a bunch of
dust and soot and co2 a greenhouse gas
and that suit covers the ice making it
darker allowing more radiation to absorb
on the surface and melts the ice and you
have that positive feedback we going
in the opposite direction co2 as well as
a greenhouse caps warms the atmosphere
so that is how we got out of it now Pinu
climatologists like myself can also use
quantitative tools such as stable
isotope geochemistry in addition to the
rock record to better understanding past
clients one of those tools that we use
is stable isotopes these unlike the
radiogenic isotopes of uranium in led
that we use for dating they do not decay
they simply differ on advance so for
example oxygen has isotopes stable
isotope so oxygen in seawater can either
have the common oxygen 16 with 8 protons
and neutrons or it can have the rare
version flavor of oxygen with 8 protons
and 10 neutrons oxygen-18 those spinning
cartoons up here so they simply differ
on mass and because it is easier to
evaporate a lighter isotopes and heavier
isotope water vapor precipitation and
snow is more abundant in oxygen 16 than
the seawater from which it evaporated so
very cold time periods depict it down
here ice traps more 60 no on the
continent and so seawater during cold
time periods is heavier meaning it has
more oxygen 18 than seawater than warmer
so we can use this phenomena and look at
fossils including these cute little
critters but there for a metra here draw
these tiny single-celled organisms that
live in the division and because they
grow their shells sea water they could
rate oxygen from that seawater into
their
carbonate shells we can grind them up
dissolve them basically destroy them and
get a record of temperature because the
ratio of 18 out of 60 now is temperature
dependent we can develop things called
oxygen isotope under Kurt like this one
here this is for the time period the
late cretaceous when dinosaurs are
roaming the planet and as you can see at
the peak of learning based on oxygen
isotopes the global mean annual
temperatures were 10 to 18 degrees c
warmer than they are today is 14 so what
did it look like actually tend to 80
degree c warmer than it is today very
different you can kind of see continent
outlines that look like today but what's
striking especially for those of us of
us is that there is a shallow tropical
intercontinental sequin that stretches
from the Arctic to the Gulf this is
because there's no I slip Olson see
lower and higher in addition because
there's so much warmer the tropical belt
is expanded actually have alligator
fossils in Alaska they don't do so well
today so this is what we call a
greenhouse climate the levels of
greenhouse gases are much higher during
the late cretaceous another example of
the greenhouse climate is what we call
the eocene about 50 million years ago so
after the age of the dinosaurs when
mammals are involving looks more like
today
malaya mountains yet the Isthmus of
Panama is not formed and still have no I
suppose we think based on other
geochemical proxies and that suggests
levels of co2 that they were around 500
to 1500 parts per million that is
compared to the pre-industrial levels of
co2 before the Industrial Revolution
around 280 parts per million co2 so
because of those higher levels of
greenhouse gases the planet is much
warmer as a lush tropical world I look
something like this we're mammals were
evolving these are actually early horse
ancestors that were about the size of
dolls that live back then um so you know
these are fascinating time periods that
we all study it's gracious any pity plan
it's just as their fleet interesting and
totally different from the way the world
looks today one of the other important
reason scientists are interested in
studying kiddo finest is because by
studying the past and how the hearth
reacting to increase greenhouse gases we
can better understand how the earth will
react will react to the future to human
emissions of co2 now this past year we
have cake and the landmark level of
around 400 parts per million co2
compares that to e pre-industrial level
and here are some projections of earth's
temperature
here today for the future 2015 20 100
now that level of 400 parts per million
hasn't been that high since the pliocene
around four million years ago when
Deavers average temperatures were 24
degrees warmer than another time period
is commonly studied by David
climatologist is the Paley CBS scene
thermal maximum you can see here a rapid
warming event that rapid warming the
increase of greenhouse gases at that
time that caught it is around them the
scale that is happening now due to
humans so what's really important not
just for curiosity's although that is
what happening to it initially finding
fossils on camping trips and going
museums is that we can use the past of
Earth's climate to better inform policy
to make plans so that our societies
prepared for when the world we know
today becomes the earth so that ality
and question